我知道我可能对于妈妈这个身份的话，
我可能要求的太多了啊，
但是没有办法，
因为孩子跟妈妈接触的浓度和频率是最高的，
所以只有对妈妈要求高一点，
才有可能有一个幸福的孩子。
我是在四五线城市，
是体制内的，
月收入大概一万，
我是单亲妈妈，
带了一个儿子，
我儿子22岁了，
我每个月就是要还5000块钱的贷款，
我儿子呢，
他吧性格特别的胆小，
他也不太爱沟通，
做什么事情呢，
没有积极性，
但是我感觉他这个逻辑思维也不差，
他自己也说，
他就是有点摆烂的心理，
因为他是专科毕业，
毕业之后也没有什么好工作好找，
因为就是我们做父母的吧，
都想在孩子就业或者是以后买房子找对象，
都想托举一下吧，
可能就是考虑的比较多一些，
他毕业之后就不停的给他说再学一些技术了，
反正就是想办法赚钱吧，
因为他在买房子这方面我帮不了他，
他没有积极性，
一开始的时候是就干淘宝的客服，
他学的是电子商务，
工资也不高，
想让他换工作，
他就不想动，
上了一段时间就在。
那个小区做了一个那个什么形象岗的，
又干了几个月，
也是劝他赶快换工作，
形象岗就好像保安一样，
长久的一个，
没有发展空间。
一开始的时候说他不听，
后来自己想通了，
他就说不想干了，
说去找他爸，
他爸在南方的一线城市，
但是他爸不想让他去，
他爸爸在南方一线城市，
呃，
也是一个老小区，
也买了房子，
他爸给他找了一个，
就干顺丰快递嘛，
一开始的时候他到那儿之后，
他不太适应，
乐地呢想回来，
我家人和我朋友也都劝他爷爷去世之前嘛，
给他留了两套房子，
但是就是不过户，
给他当是给他，
但就不能卖，
朋友都劝我，
意思就是说我以后再买房子啊，
这些我帮不了他，
在经济上就是希望给他爸爸培养培养感情，
毕竟是男方一线城市，
觉得在那里是不是可以更多一点的机会，
孩子在那里可以，
他不能融入到他爸爸那个家庭里面，
我感觉他爸爸已经其实不想让他去，
不想管他，
但是去了吧，
也算热情，
他爸爸有再生小孩吗？
比如一个儿子，
他再生那个儿子多大，
上高中呢？
他爸爸明显其实对这个大儿子其实已经是放弃的状态了，
是吧，
都不愿意让这个大儿子去他的城市，
那咱说句实话。
是明显瞧不上这个大儿子，
我就是我心里也纠结也难过，
我也是尊重孩子的想法，
我之前最早的刚毕业的时候，
我劝过他，
我说你不行，
你就开个网店，
或者说找你爸爸那边有什么发展，
反正你不能就这样干，
你得赶快想办法赚钱买房子，
一开始没同意，
到后期的时候他自己想去找他爸爸姐妹，
我说句实话啊，
如果说我们自己的人生都过得不是很好，
不是很成功，
放弃去指导孩子的人生吧，
如果他是善良的，
他是正常人，
他有同理心，
他不添乱，
他不伤害别人，
他不对为非作歹，
他不欺压弱小，
真的放弃指导他的人生，
也放弃他说要跟着他爸干嘛干嘛的，
因为他爸明显是瞧不上他了，
你让他去跟着一个瞧不上他的人在一起的话，
只能更打击他的自信，
就是照顾好他的身体，
他只要是身体是健康的，
精神是健康的，
他就好好活着，
因为爷爷奶奶去世了之后，
房子是他的对不对？
答应了房子是他的对不对？
他没有住宿这方面的危险的情况下，
他是很难饿死自己的，
我就不太理解他为什么说这个房子给他就是不能卖，
我们家利他那个房子是一个多小时的车程，
老人，
房子给你过户到你。
底下了，
你卖了之后，
老人一辈子就攒这么点儿棺材本，
你卖了之后的话，
以你孩子现在的心性能力，
他连防诈骗的能力他都未必有，
不要卖才正常呢，
你自己琢磨一下吧，
就以你儿子那个心性，
以你儿子的社会化的程度，
他连防诈骗的能力他都没有，
这房子如果卖了几十万上百万在他手里的话，
三下五除二就被人家骗走了，
也有可能是谈恋爱的捞女，
所以有可能不卖才是好的，
你为什么要寄希望于他卖掉这个房子呢？
他不卖这个房子的话，
他有一个安身立命的所在，
也不指望这个孩子说将来还能上北上广深，
能立住脚了。
北上广深现在那么多大学毕业的，
研究生毕业的，
博士毕业的都立不住脚，
你的孩子又内向，
又没有什么真才实学，
他在大城市他也立不住脚，
还不如就退一步，
就保住了小地方的房子，
一世安稳，
平安健康。
因为快过年的时候呢，
他说回家过年，
我说你是打算在这里找工作，
还是回去找你爸，
他就说找他爸，
就说再接着干，
虽然欠，
但是我也是尊重他，
但是我每次听他给他爸爸沟通的，
就是说元宵节的时候，
第二天我问他，
我说你元宵节怎么过的，
他说他送戒了，
他爸问。
他出去吃快餐嘛，
吃自助餐嘛，
他说不去，
他说那为什么不能让爸爸等等你，
他说他问我了，
我忙他们就自己去了，
然后我感觉又过一个元宵节，
也没有一块吃饭，
就只是问了一下孩子，
反正就是在那边吧，
就是他只管孩子吃饱，
看着就想，
其他的他也不多问，
孩子说每次回家的时候，
走到门口，
我得想一想，
我不想进去，
我一听他说这个话吧，
我就特别难过，
我就想问一下我们老师，
请教一下你，
像这种情况下，
各位家长嘛，
应该怎样引导孩子，
或者说我什么也不说嘛，
什么也不做嘛，
我就心里特别难过，
那我问一下你现在自己是干什么工作的呀？
一个月收入有多少钱呀？
你现在又组建家庭了吗？
你现在自己名下有什么资产吗？
你的人生有什么目标吗？
我一个月1万块钱，
然后就是房子是你自己贷款买的，
贷款有5000，
然后我单身，
那你这头是吧，
你自己房子也已经买了，
那你将来还可以，
你就这一个儿子说你将来还可以给孩子留下一套房呢，
那爷爷奶奶再给他留下来两套房，
那这孩子手上三套房，
只要这个孩子他平安，
他健康，
他不走歪门邪道，
他不伤害别人，
我感觉。
只是孩子很好啊，
他饿不死自己的，
至于你想让他得到，
比如说父亲的关爱，
父亲的重视，
这玩意儿得不到，
因为你从他父亲的态度可以看出来，
他对这个大儿子就没有什么缘分，
没有什么感情，
他并不想说他把他的资源、
感情倾泻在大儿子身上，
他不会得不到这个东西，
又不是我们能决定的事情，
你焦虑也没有用，
你难过也没有用，
因为人和人之间的缘分就是单线的，
也是奇妙的，
你觉得他作为孩子的亲生父亲应该对孩子怎么样，
但是他确实他跟这个孩子没有什么感情，
他瞧不上这个孩子，
他不这么做的话，
他也不犯法。
那龙玉老师可能是我的想法，
也可能是比较传统吧，
因为孩子就是二十四五岁，
马上就面临找对象了，
到时候一般就是要房子了，
因为我没办法给他解决，
我觉得是这样的啊，
我接下来要讲的话，
我会触动很多当妈妈的人，
就如果你没有本事帮他解决这个事情的话，
就别催他，
你没有本事帮他解决这个事情的话，
就别把压力给到孩子，
别老催他，
因为他不是一个事儿啊，
不是说光有个房子就行了，
他将来他生孩子养孩子，
一大堆消费，
你有本事解决吗？
你没有本事解决的话，
就别催他，
别指望他。
是玩什么也不算，
什么也不算了，
你就过好自己的日子呀，
你能给他攒钱的话，
你就多攒点钱呀，
你所想要实现的这些东西的话，
你现在都是望尘莫及的，
你现在都是手伸不出去的，
你想要父亲重视他，
这个课题在父亲那里，
决定权在父亲那里，
不在你身上，
你干不成这个事儿啊，
你想要孩子成家，
想要孩子结婚，
想要孩子生孩子，
你现在也没有这个本事去帮他实现这一点啊，
那就退而求其次的想，
幸好我孩子是健康的，
没有得什么抑郁症，
没有得什么对吧，
精神类的疾病，
没有想着天天要死要活的，
没有一天天的就沉迷于打游戏，
没有一天天就沉于我，
没有一天天就沉迷于网恋，
那他是个正常人，
是个健康的人，
他能活着，
就算我今天死了，
你儿子是不是也能活着？
他是不是也能饿不死，
他也能活着？
是的，
至于说他想怎么活着，
这是他的人生课题，
他想不想结婚，
他想不想生孩子，
他想不想作为父亲，
这是他的课题，
你不给他施加压力，
他可能活得更自在，
他可能才会想一下自己想要什么。
其实我知道我可能对于妈妈这个身份的话，
我可能要求的太多了啊，
但是没有办法，
因为孩子跟妈妈接触的浓度和频率是最高的，
所以只有对妈妈要求高一点才有。
可能有一个幸福的孩子，
其实很多时候你特别典型，
你就是属于那种什么都想管的妈妈，
从小到大什么都想管的妈妈，
反而孩子跟你在一起的时候，
觉得是压抑的，
想逃避的，
她觉得什么都要管，
她会焦虑的，
是真的。
我直播间有没有当孩子的，
你凭感觉，
你一听这个姐姐，
她就是这种妈妈，
什么都想管，
大年十五的时候，
你爸有没有叫你一起吃饭，
这种事情都想掺和一下，
都想问一下，
其实孩子非常焦虑，
他只要活得好好的，
他没欺负别人，
他没有违法犯罪，
他没有为社会造成什么不利的影响，
我觉得就挺好的。
懂明老的师，
我并不是想参与，
我只是担心孩子受委屈，
这是他的事儿，
他如果说他受了委屈，
他愿意在那待着，
这也是他的事儿，
好，
我明白了，
是真的姐妹啊，
我今天跟你讲的话，
非常底层的一个逻辑就是他觉得他受委屈了，
但是他愿意在那呆着，
就表示什么呢？
表示他在那里得到的好处是大于他受的委屈的，
所以他才愿意在那呆着，
因为他就是一般呢，
他干什么就一开始干着干着，
然后就不想换地方，
我感觉可能也有这个原因，
他再回去我就干习惯了，
我就不想再去接触了新的地方，
我感觉就有这方面的原因，
他自己如果说有一天感情上受伤害了，
他受不了了，
他自己会换地。
方菲呀，
他已经24岁了，
他不是4岁，
他不需要你帮他做决定，
不需要你去保护他了，
反过来讲应该是，
他应该关心一下你有没有被老头骗，
有没有被人家骗钱才对呀，
是不是你一念放下，
万般自在，
你不知道我直播间有多少人很羡慕你儿子已经24岁了，
自己能挣口饭吃了，
不用你管着他了，
不用你给他做饭，
不用给他洗衣服，
不用你叫他起床了，
不用担心他心理不健康，
不用担心他吃不饱饭，
不用担心他这个好多人羡慕你，
你不信的话，
我直播间羡慕他这种状态的扣衣，
他已经成年人了，
他不需要你的保护了，
你需要过好你自己的日子，
你能给他多存点钱，
你就给他多存点钱，
她结不结婚是他的事儿，
她生不是孩子，
是他的事儿，
你没有本事，
没有这个能力去给他兜底，
就不要去逼他，
我最担心的是他在外面受委屈，
那是他的事儿啊，
她委屈到一定程度了，
她自己会跑呀，
她也不没长脚，
对不对？
我看到很多网友评价，
应该是我做的不好，
我这个妈妈当的非常失分，
也不能这么说吧，
只能说非常的典型，
有千千万万跟你一样的妈妈都需要松绑，
都需要明白一个道理，
就有的时候爱是会成为枷锁的，
有的时候爱会逼疯孩子的，
有的时候自以为的爱会让孩子非常沉重的负担的，
尊重自由，
就他只要不违法犯罪的。
不伤害别人，
他能养活自己挺好，
我也都是说，
你要想笃定在家里干什么工作我都支持你，
你上南方去，
我也是这样说的，
我跟你说啊，
其实孩子特别讨厌你这种说法，
你知道为什么讨厌吗？
因为你的支持是没有实质内容的，
你的支持比如说你可以拿10万块钱给他开店，
这叫支持，
比如说你可以拿多少钱给他创业，
这叫支持。
真的，
我知道，
我知道我讲这个话可能会触犯了很多当爹当妈的那个敏感的神经，
但是我告诉你，
你做儿女的这个心理和做儿女的切身感受的话，
特别讨厌父母说这种空话，
说你干什么我都支持你，
你拿什么支持我？
你有钱吗？
你支持我，
你有人脉吗？
你有经验吗？
你支持我，
你有业务方向吗？
你有支持我，
你拿什么支持？
我最讨厌你们讲这种大话空话，
你只能这么说，
你说孩子，
只要你身体健健康康的，
你平平安安的，
你是自由的，
你想怎么过，
妈妈都尊重你，
不管你在外面遇到多大的困难，
遇到多大的委屈事儿的话，
你回到妈妈这里来，
妈给你做饭，
能保证你吃得饱穿得暖，
你这么说没问题，
嗯，
我也是这样说的呀，
我说你什么时间回来都可以，
你只要是感到委屈了，
你什么时间来妈妈都欢迎。
我看到很多网友都好像在说我，
别人说你什么也不重要，
重要的是你自己要放下，
可能是我自己原生家庭也。
不太好吧，
我爸爸妈妈就是特别重男轻女，
就是我性格也是比较胆小，
就是比较懦弱一点，
如果你能想明白这一点的话，
母子关系能处挺好，
一切由他，
你做好你自己啊，
好，
我感觉我没有，
就是从来没有强迫孩子，
就是这些大的方面，
就说你要干什么，
我没有强迫过他，
还有什么别的问题要问我吗？
没有人好，
那就这样啊，
拜拜，
今天讲的这个话题可能会让很多做妈妈的人心里面委屈了，
不舒服了，
但是现实就是这样，
现实就是妈妈付出了所有爱，
关心，
但是孩子得到的是负面的东西，
孩子得到的就是窒息，
焦虑、
压力，
好多孩子人生最重要的课题是要逃离妈妈，
嗯，
我不知道我直播间有多少这样的孩子，
你人生的一个首要任务是要逃离妈妈，
有没有，
有的甚至接妈妈的电话，
就只要是妈妈打电话过来的话，
他就开始这边发抖，
手发抖，
心脏开始突突的跳，
因为一听妈妈讲话他就焦虑，
一听妈妈讲话他受不了，
但是你说妈妈有什么干什么伤天害理的事儿吗？
伤害他吗？
抱着他了吗？
冻着他没有？
妈妈都是出于爱，
妈妈都是出于关怀，
妈妈都是出于担忧，
但是妈妈的这种爱、
关怀和担忧会传染，
会像病毒一样传染给孩子，
始终让孩子觉得自己状态不够好，
让孩子觉得自己现在什么都不对，
还不够好，
还不够。
成熟就是我们作为女性，
作为有了孩子的女人，
我们要以史为鉴，
以别人为鉴，
以你的妈妈为鉴，
以你看到的这些控制欲比较强的，
全身心都投入在孩子身上，
关注在孩子身上的妈妈违建，
然后从我们开始，
尽量做一个心大一点的妈妈，
尽量做一个能够课题分离的妈妈，
就是我的任务是做好我的事情，
我的工作，
我的事业，
我的人设，
我做一个宽容的、
耐心的，
不强迫你的这样一个妈妈。
至于说你将来能不能成才，
你将来能不能发达，
你将来会不会想结婚，
会不会想生孩子，
这是你自己的事情，
你需要在这个社会上去寻找你自己的良师益友，
你己的人生目标，
你自己希望的渴望的生活模式，
过的那样的日子。
我作为一个妈妈，
我的孩子一定要考上985，
我才有面子，
我的孩子一定要考上211，
一定要在30岁之前结婚生孩子，
我才有面子。
我的面子在母爱面前是不值钱的。
我忘了我最初养他的目的，
养他的心性是我爱他，
我愿意为他付出时间和精力，
而我的面子是不值钱的，
因为你也没什么面子，
我们普通人，
作为芸芸众生，
你有什么面子？
谁在乎你的面子？
你的面子值几个钱？
我先立一个flag，
就算以后我的孩子是个学渣，
就算以后我的孩子他一事无成，
我也不会觉得他丢了我的面子，
这是他的课题，
我也不会觉得我自己失败了，
因为我的人生把我过好就行，
把我过好就心理健康，
身体健康，
不为非作歹，
不违法犯罪，
对社会没有危害，
我就很成功了，
把我自己做好，
我就成功了。
比如说我的孩子将来愿意干什么，
这是他的人生课题啊。
我不会觉得说我的孩子将来在事业上如果没有超越我的话，
我就没面子。
但是如果我没有把他培养成一个遵纪守法，
在乎别人感受，
心地善良，
有同理心，
如果我没有把他培养成这样一个人的话，
那是我的失败，
那是我的失职。
记得点赞关注哦。